Ravi I'm a star the executive director
for the shuttle environment and energy
research institute we have a quiet of a
challenge if you look into job creation
and we could take many different
dimensions that i mentioned that i would
like to take on this important question
is looking at a new paradigm shift in
total resource management we are living
in a crisis mode and i think we need to
realize that the challenges that lie
ahead in terms of the water water
security or water in security in the
region food insecurity in the region as
well as the energy in security requires
us to be looking at a new integrated
thinking to manage these resources and
that and that integrated thinking needs
to be up hold up hold it and supported
by new new breed of talented young
people that in today's curriculum is not
providing them with the right tools to
manage these complex systems so I think
if we look at the new job creation in
the future I would would like to
emphasize the role of sustainability the
role of integrated thinkers that are so
much needed that would allow for a
better resource utilization for a better
integrated thinking and sustaining the
future of this region
Oh